[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mardi 26 avril voici
les titres
sont installés depuis un an cette femme
atteinte de trisomie 21 vives au sein
d'une colocation à viroflay c'est la
seconde structure du genre dans le
département pour aller vers plus
d'autonomie le projet est porté par
l'association des maisons saint joseph
et la fondation pour le logement social
près de soixante mille réfugiés
ukrainiens seraient arrivés en france
depuis le début de la guerre contre la
russie à voisins le bretonneux l'accueil
va plus loin la ville fournit
directement des logements à deux
familles qui tentent de reprendre le
cours de leur vie nous les avons
rencontrés et puis le mythique rendez
vous des passionnés d'automobile
s'élancer aujourd'hui des yvelines le
tour auto 2022 a pris le départ ce matin
du château de rambouillet 250 bolide de
collection vont sillonner la france
direction andorre-la-vieille
retour tout à l'heure également sur la
journée du souvenir des victimes de la
déportation
elles avaient lieu dimanche dernier
viviane boussier président des amis de
la fondation pour la mémoire de la
déportation 60,18 sera notre invité
[Musique]
c'est un projet rendu possible grâce à
la fondation pour le logement social et
l'association des maisons saint joseph
une colocation de femmes en situation de
handicap mental a vu le jour en mars
2021 en plein coeur de viroflay elle
loge dans une belle villa en meulière
bordé d'un grand jardin le but favoriser
leur inclusion le reportage de céline
charles
c'est la maison du bonheur dans cette
grande bâtisse flambant neuf cette femme
en situation de handicap mental
cohabitent dans un esprit familial
chacune dispose de sa propre chambre et
salle de bain le salon la buanderie ou
encore la cuisine sont eux des lieux
communs
d'abord
c'est le martian beaucoup aussi une
pièce plus si important dans la mission
ils apparaissent pas qu un champ c'est
le jardin et si l'univers si mon espace
le matin un petit noir mais après elles
partent elles partent pour pour aller
travailler elle travaille toute la
journée en jeu leur handicap ne leur
permet pas de vivre seule dans
son appartement de pendant deux
maîtresses de maison aussi éducatrice
spécialisée ce relais pour les
superviser faire le lien avec les
familles et proposer des activités
jardinage jeux de société tâches
ménagères les sept colocataires
participe pleinement à la vie
quotidienne le jardin d'enfants
d'immigrés on se dépense on se défoule
en fait sien l'adage on oublie préfet
ciment
on a les accompagne pour plus le
quotidien faire la cuisine avec elle le
rappelait les services certains diaby j
ai récupéré le courrier certains de la
cuisine et de la vaisselle matin et soir
une maison qui a comme objectif de leur
offrir un maximum d'autonomie tout en
brisant l'isolément liées au handicap
c'est la mine une famille normale comme
je suis papa maman s'est pareillement
peut vivre
asseyez on peut pas s'allier en paix à
laquelle joie de vivre au salut henry
aux play off et des choses donc
l'occasion de ce qui est sympa c'est
d'être avec ses amis de pouvoir partager
des vies des fois des moments qu'on
vidéo pas se retrouver tout seul le soir
pour dîner un habitat à taille humaine
qui se présente comme une alternative au
foyer ou aux instituts spécialisés
une colocation du même style existent
également pour cette jeune garçon à
versailles
après les accueils d'urgence
l'accompagnement auprès des réfugiés
ukrainiens se transforme près de 8
millions ont fui leur pays en guerre
60000 serait arrivé en france à voisins
le bretonneux la ville a choisi de
fournir des logements à deux familles
elles sont actuellement hébergés dans
deux maisons voisines la vie reprend
doucement pour eux pour elle malgré des
souvenirs douloureux mélanie poquet et
céline charles à lisa un an depuis ce
dimanche la petite ukrainienne vient de
faire ses premiers pas mais en france
avec sa maman sa tante et ses cousines
elle vit aujourd'hui à voisins le
bretonneux
le fait d'être dans cette maison ça nous
aide énormément de nous adapter de nous
changer les idées d'oublier un peu le
cauchemar qui se passe en ukraine on
reprend la vie on apprend le français
ont fait connaissance avec les voisins
on communique avec déjà 3 et un
quotidien où la peinture et la musique
ont repris leur place daria une amie
installé à saint quentin en yvelines
depuis plusieurs années est là pour
traduire et les accompagner même s'ils
sont déjà bien installés g continue
quand même à en occuper d'elle parce que
je comprends très bien que ce que c'est
d'être dans un pays dont la langue on ne
parle pas ça peut être difficile il ya
beaucoup des questions administratives
médicales
pour les écoles pour les activités et
c'est donc organisations demandent coco
dead et si je peux la porte à porte
daria est aussi un lien pour la famille
d'oksana et anastasia partie de czerny
fle 8 mars avec leur petite fille elles
sont aussi hébergé sur voisins le
bretonneux elle essaye de panser leurs
plaies le mari d'anastasia est mort dans
leur fuite il avait 43 ans et a été
abattu par un sniper près de kiev les
trois femmes sont menacées par des
soldats les proches d'oksana sont encore
en ukraine à marioupol hautmont au piano
l'homme le plus important pour nous
c'est qu'il n'y ait pas d'avion
au-dessus de nous qui lancent des bombes
la vie reprend des couleurs parce que
quand on partait de notre ville de notre
pays on avait l'impression qu'il n'y
avait plus de couleurs que tout était en
noir et blanc c'était extrêmement triste
et douloureux l'accueil de ces deux
familles a été rendue possible par les
équipes municipales de
voisins-le-bretonneux la mairie a mise à
disposition de maison de quatre pièces
de fonction une chaîne de solidarité
s'est ensuite développée il a fallu
meubler les maisons et nous avons a fait
appel à toutes les bonnes volontés un
bel élan de
bel élan de solidarité
bon carrefour market qui a mis à
disposition tout le matériel dont on a
besoin dans une maison micro-ondes
cafetière planche à repasser enfin voilà
tous ces petits détails le promoteur
vinci oublié qui a donné
les frigos et des
des machines à laver le linge on nous
avons également un bailleur social qui
nous a fourni des meubles les enfants
ont été scolarisés dans des
établissements heavy noyau beaux-arts à
versailles des bons alimentaires du ccas
sont mises à leur disposition ainsi
qu'un appel aux dons la commune
accompagne aussi d'autres réfugiés
accueillis chez des administrés deux
jours après la réélection des manuels
macro comme président de la république
les formations politiques se tournent
désormais vers les législatifs scrutin
que certains présentent comme le
troisième tour de la présidentielle et
notamment jean luc mélenchon qui a
appelé les français à aller lire allez
lire premier ministre dans la 12e
circonscription des yvelines ali rabais
soutien du candidat de la france
insoumise ne sera pas candidat à la
députation le maire génération de
trappes l'a confirmé au micro de tv 78
en tant que seul édile de gauche de
cette circonscription de cette commune
il estime néanmoins avoir une
responsabilité dans ces élections l'élu
va réunir dans les prochains jours les
représentants de la gauche locale
l'objectif c'est de présenter une
candidature commune dans cette
circonscription perdue par l'ancien
socialiste benoît hamon en 2017 elle a
été sous bannière de la république en
marche avec nadia comme député entre
2017 et 2020 avant d'être ravie par les
républicains en 2020 et l'élection de
l'ancien maire de bois d'arcy philippe
benassaya on écoute ali rabais interrogé
par patrick jacques de dixmude
moi je ne serai pas candidat puisque je
suis maire de trappes est pleinement à
ma tâche on ne peut pas être maire et
député je ne le souhaite pas je suis
contre le cumul des mandats donc je me
concentre sur 30 mais j'estime qu'en
tant que maire de trappes j'ai une
responsabilité pour soutenir encourager
les candidats qui se présenteront et
pour faire en sorte que ces candidats
soient les candidats de toute la gauche
et pas seulement d'un parti donc je
livrerai dès demain et si les français
le décide ils peuvent élire une majorité
dans un mode de scrutin qui est
différent une majorité qui viendraient
cadenassé quelque part la politique du
président macron il l'obligé à mener
politique sociale avec un premier
ministre qui serait choisi parmi la
majorité parlementaire donc la gauche a
encore les moyens si elle est unie de
remporter une majorité circonscription
et pourquoi pas la 11e circonscription
des yvelines
[Musique]
chaque année le dernier dimanche du mois
d'avril les cérémonies sont organisées
partout en france pour se souvenir des
victimes de la déportation cette année
la journée nationale avait donc lieu
dimanche dernier le 24 avril pour en
parler avec mon plateau viviane boussier
bonsoir présidente de l'afm des 78 c'est
les amis de la fondation de la mémoire
de la déportation dans les yvelines
délégation dans les yvelines alors juste
avant de parler de cette journée avec
vous je vous propose de regarder le
portrait de cette yvelinoise jacques une
fleury déportés et résistants sous
l'occupation allemande pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale en 2010 est elle
nous avait ouvert les portes de son
appartement versaillais pour nous
raconter son histoire en témoignage que
je vous propose de redécouvrir avec
justin brasil en 1942 sous la france
occupée la jeune versaillaise jakin
fleury alors âgé de 20 ans entre en
résistance avec sa famille elle
distribuer tracts journaux clandestins
participent à des réseaux de
renseignement et prend chaque jour de
plus en plus de risques
quand je rentrais dans paris avec mon
petit chargement de journaux clandestins
on pouvait être arrêté dans le métro
dans les rues dans les gares dont les
gars surtout où il y avait la police
française la police allemande pour nous
la gestapo
arrêté jakin fleury letang février 1944
dans son appartement versailles et elle
est alors envoyé avec sa famille à la
prison de fresnes puis déporté en
allemagne s'ensuivent sept jours de
transfert confiné dans un wagon
direction le camp de concentration de
ravensbrück
nous recevions un numéro puisque à
partir de cet instant nous n'étions plus
des êtres humains nous étions d'échec
c'est à dire des morceaux c'est là c'est
la négation de l'humain c'est
d'indication de lettres
en l'espace d'un an jacqueline changera
trois fois de camp elle travaillera pour
l'armurerie allemande en tant que
prisonnière en 1945 elle s'évade avec sa
mère et deux autres détenus elles seront
rapatriés en france par l'armée rouge
comme on avait toujours vécu par terre
je trouvais les bords des trottoirs
et sanguinaire ça m'attirait pour
m'asseoir et j'entends j'entendrai
toujours ma mère me le dire mais tu ne
peux pas faire fin nous sommes à
versailles
un témoignage douloureux que cette
résistance était attaché a rapporté
pendant plus de 70 ans dans les collèges
et lycées un devoir de mémoire pour
transmettre son héritage culturel aux
nouvelles générations
au fond quand on a peut-être très dans
un camp c'est aussi quelque chose que je
dis aux enfants que je rencontre les
professions évidemment on ne sort jamais
complètement d'accord il n'y a pas un
jour où on ne retrouve pas quelque chose
comptait les jours depuis sept depuis
depuis 2005 il ya ceux qui jouent
sans compter tout ce qu'on a laissé
toutes leurs composantes boosting
tout ce qu'on y en a encore
dans caire
voilà pour ce témoignage précieux
d'ailleurs viviane boussier on parle
d'une d'un témoin direct de ces
événements et ces témoignages au fil des
années vont être de plus en plus rares
ils sont précieux aujourd'hui comment
entretenir j'ai envie de vous dire cette
mémoire avec ben ali témoins directs qui
vont disparaître aussi petit à petit oui
dans les civils n'y a plus que deux
déportés qui peuvent témoigner donc
madame fleury vous avez donc entendue
dans votre témoignage l'âme christophe
qui habite en cours donc ce sont les
deux seuls qui restent et je crois que
vous touchez du doigt ici une fin une
des problématiques qui se posent
actuellement parce que c'est vrai que
quand on écoute le témoignage qu'il ya
un côté humain et qui prend aux tripes
en quelque sorte de ce qu'a vécu et
madame fleury et de ce qu'ont vécu les
les déportés mais je crois que l'autre
aspect qui apparaît ici et qui répond
exactement à votre question c'est
comment transmettre parce que beaucoup
de ceux qui qui c'est de transmettre
d'abord ne sont pas les témoins donc ce
ne sont pas des témoignages que l'on
peut apporter bien sûr ce sont souvent
bondés descendants enfants c'est le cas
de monsieur fleury qui avec lequel on
travaille on en parlera si vous voulez
je travaille on en parlera se voulait un
moment donné non mais sont donc des
enfants des petits enfants mais pour eux
c'est pour les descendants la 3e
génération on en est là maintenant c'est
loin c'est le passé en quoi ça nous
touche exactement et je pense que c'est
bon peut-être justement de se rappeler
d'un côté vous faites allusion au mot
devoir de mémoire
d'après ce qui ressort de ce que dit
madame fleury il y à bien l'idée de
devoir séduire c'est peut-être à deux
voire de se rappeler mais c'est aussi un
devoir de transmettre et c'est un devoir
aussi de travailler sur cette mémoire
qui devient de l'histoire maintenant on
va voir seulement voilà vous travaillez
justement sur sur cette thématique alors
vous parlez de se rappeler il ya un
événement forcément on en parlait en
préambule de ce reportage c'est la
journée nationale de souvenir des
victimes de la déportation qui a lieu
chaque
chaque année donc dernier dimanche
d'avril ça c'est un événement important
pour aussi se rappeler oui alors d'abord
cette journée en effet c'est une journée
nationale c'est à dire que il y à une
loi et c'est depuis 1954 et que cette
cette loi a créé donc cette journée
nationale que les mairies doivent donc
célébré par des cérémonies le
pavoisement etc et alors petite
parenthèse cette année en effet c'était
assez compliqué étant donné que les
élections tombait ce jour-là donc
c'était assez difficile à organiser
si bien que le ministère de l'intérieur
à m'en diras concertée s'est concerté
avec les fondations qui ont finalement
décidé que pour faciliter les choses les
préfets pouvait accepter que cette
journée soit commémoré il est quelques
jours qui précédaient dimanche c'est
bien que certaines villes ont commémoré
à versailles par exemple le mercredi à
guyancourt ma commune dimanche d'autres
villes dans différents jours donc ça
peut donner l'impression qui a pas
d'harmonie mais l'idée quand même là les
dc2 commémorer ce journée cette journée
vous avez reçu alors virtuellement
pendant la crise et elles ont parlé
toute la difficulté aussi de de ce se
rappeler alors que les cérémonies elle a
été reportée ou annulée en raison de la
crise sanitaire ça veut dire que depuis
deux trois ans il ya ces perturbé sans
perturber ses cerveaux vers turbé pour
des raisons donc salutaire que vous
évoquez mais ils ont quand même eu lieu
même si c'est difficile on y tient et
même si certaines communes ne l'ont pas
fait cette année je pense qu'on a pour
le coup le devoir pour reprendre votre
expression de rappeler que c'est bas de
voir puisque c'est la loi qui l'obligent
de le faire c'est le seul moment de
l'année où on peut tous vivre autour de
ce souvenir est pas seulement le
souvenir fut tient parce que se rappeler
bon souvenir pour les jeunes qu'est ce
que ça représente un gars 77 ans pour
eux c'est plus que du vieux mais
pourquoi on le fait et qu'est ce que ça
représente aujourd'hui comment le vit
aujourd'hui c'est c'est l'idée qui est
derrière cette commémoration
cette commémoration est votre travail
aussi se déroulent tout au long de
l'année un la fsd 78 rappel vous êtes le
la présidente de l'afm des 78 quelles
sont les missions les actions vous
déployez sur le département il ya
j'imagine aussi une transmission en
parliez de transmission auprès des
jeunes il ya aussi des messages à faire
passer il est oui alors en fait donc là
les amis de la fondation pour la même la
déportation dit rarement lanthier mais a
effleuré ça va tellement plus vite et
puis bon on voit pourquoi pourquoi on
est là donc la délégation est créée
depuis
1998 on est déjà un bon moment et elle a
été créée à peine dix ans après la
création de la fondation vraiment la
déportation qui a une
une triple mission quelque sorte qui est
la mission de transmettre voilà la
mission de travail historique donc de
recherches historiques et de défense de
la mémoire ce sont ces trois missions de
la fondation mais comme une fondation ne
peut pas avoir d' adhérents
elle est donc représenté dans tous les
départements par les amis de la
fondation et c'est donc nous avons
exactement les mêmes missions seulement
avec des adhérents qui sont là sur le
terrain donc on a chaque délégation est
la nôtre en particulier fait enfin
intervient comme elle le peut des
activités bien précise que si vous
voulez quelque chose exemples
d'activités alors écoutez je pense qu'il
pourrait évoquer ces trois missions
vous prendre disons que trois exemples
en quelque sorte pour chaque fois delà
de ce que fait la fondation
un exemple très concret et qui date d'il
y à m'avoir à peine huit jours
à des collège de trappes
à préparer et ce sera doucement notre
explication de l'activité à préparer le
concours national de recenser la
déportation cnrd de cette année et avec
justesse les professeurs
désirait que les élèves puissent montrer
faut mettre en valeur ce qu'elles ont
fait
donc nous avons cherché ensemble comment
à partir de ce power plant sur le thème
du concours donc 2022 il vient de se
terminer et les copie est envoyée en
quelque sorte il avait quelques jours
les élèves pouvaient à présenter et
faire passer en tels que ça ce qu'elles
ont vécu enfin ce qu'ils ont vécu parce
qu'il y avait un incident dans ce
collège donc je peux vous voyez c'est
une des premières activités comment
faire pour transmettre aux jeunes et
avec d'autres moyens modernes
en fait leur témoignage c'était un
powerpoint c'était des interviews donc
c'est une autre façon on n'est plus dans
ces témoignages d'il ya 50 ans mais
c'est une autre façon donc c'est une
participation par la transmission donc
aux jeunes donc c'est une activité parmi
d'autres malheureusement on arrive à la
fin de cet entretien mais en tout cas ça
fait partie de ces de ses activités de
la ffd 78 je rappelle vous avez précisé
tout à l'heure c'est les amis de la
fondation pour la mémoire de la
déportation dans les yvelines d'ailleurs
il ya une page facebook qui existe un de
cette délégation territoriale dans les
yvelines y aussi le site de l'afm des
pour avoir toutes les informations sur
la fm des amis de la fondation pour la
mémoire de la déportation
merci viviane vous sied à être venus en
plateau pour parler de ce sujet
c'est un rendez vous mythique des
passionnés d'automobile tour auto
édition 2022 s'est élancé du château de
rambouillet ce matin jusqu'à samedi les
quelques 250 bolide de collection
apporte arpenteront la france pour un
final à andorre-la-vieille sur la ligne
de départ ce matin bixente mais rien
senti steban plus arriver à peu près à
cette heure c'est encore un moment une
parenthèse
pourvu pour les passionnés qui est
extraordinaire ils se sont levés aux
aurores pour contempler chaque cylindre
et les passionnés d'automobiles étaient
au bord des routes ce mardi 26 avril en
amont du château de rambouillet où se
tenait le départ du prestigieux rendez
vous du tour auto 2022 d'habitude ça
passe pas par par ce département et là
c'est c'est bien ça va rambouillet
rambouillet ils vont souvent si
l'historique du sport automobile
français par un français et même
internationale et puis
et
c'est un plaisir c'est une musique
un peu plus loin près du château sa fin
un équipage de pilotes se prépare est
encore au départ de cette 31e édition
effectivement surveille nos compteurs on
est un peu et fébrile à ce matin en nous
échangions avec d'autres pilotes nous
sommes fébriles on surveille les
températures de volée température
d'huile que sa fille par on va regarder
en dessous sans oublier bien sûr tout
profiter du moment et un magasin de
jouets à ciel ouvert pour convaincant et
puis le cadre aussi pas bien parce que
des voitures évidemment quand on est
passionné on en voit très souvent mais
le lieu le lieu en rajoute un petit peu
de magie à tout simple en tout plus de
250 voitures de collection se suivront
lors d'un périple qui durera cinq jours
première étape on finit à la baule donc
ce retour de mr là c'est un rallye qui
va se disputer sur l'ouest de la france
parce que de la baule nous allons à
limoges après deux lignes ja bordeaux de
bordeaux à pau ils arrivent et se fait à
andorre donc on attend tous avec
impatience l'arrivée parce que je pense
que la montée est là d'andorre avec novo
et poli ça va être il fallut ce qui me
surprend à chaque fois c'est l'émotion
au bord la mi-août où il ya énormément
de monde le départ s'est achevée en fin
de matinée soit un peu plus de trois
heures pour laisser à chaque bolide le
soin de faire rugir son moteur
avant de vous laisser cette distinction
pour le parc de la brune et riz le site
d'orgeval a reçu le label ensemble
arboré remarquable samedi dernier il a
été remis par l'association arbres
notamment pour le pain noir à l'entrée
du parc et l'alignement des châtaigniers
datant du 19e siècle une belle
récompense pour les amis de la brune et
riz l'association qui agit pour
préserver le parc et ses nombreux arbres
des d'exception et datant de 200 voire
300 ans
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité dans un instant
retrouver le 7-8 culture présentée par
célia agathe son goût elle sera
notamment cette émission a dédié au
château de breteuil à choisel pour
parler des nouvelles scènes nouvelle
scène ne compte proposer sur place belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]